comme tous les jeudis c'est la chronique
et aux claviers bonsoir bonsoir on va
parler on va rester dans le domaine des
vacances complètement oui l'été approche
chacun prépare ses vacances mais le
budget des français est serré selon le
dernier baromètre ipsos seuls 162 % des
français ont l'intention de partir cette
année un chiffre en baisse de 8% par
rapport à l'année dernière et un triste
record pour la france depuis 2005
alors pour partir cet été sans vider son
portefeuille un entrepreneur ebe noir à
trouver une solution
il a créé il ya deux mois un site
internet grand ping pong com qui met en
relation des particuliers qui cherche un
endroit où poser leurs tentes et des
partis et d'autres campeurs pardon non
non il est composé leurs tentes et des
particuliers qui du coup ont un jardin
pour accepter ces fameux campeurs je
vous invite ce suivi ces jeunes
entrepreneurs s'appelle joseph léopold
ii bonsoir avec nous sur ce plateau
alors tout simplement pourquoi avoir
créé ce site c'était vraiment une
question d'économie d'argent ou alors
est-ce qu'il ya aussi derrière un lien
social une rencontre avec les habitants
me dire qu'à la base était une raison un
peu personnel
moi je fais un grand amateur de toile de
tente et à chaque vacances je fait
camping sauvage
malheureusement c'est illégal donc je
cherchais à une solution pour faire du
camping en pleine nature de manière
légale et en revenant d'un voyage en
italie
je rentre chez moi et j'avais oublié mes
clés et donc je passe la nuit dans mon
jardin
voilà je m'installe dans mon jardin avec
ma tante et ces deux là ne me vient
l'idée mais pourquoi je proposerai pas
mon jardin à d'autres campeurs qui
passerait dans la région ça pourrait
intéresser des personnes et j'ai aussi
photo titre que je crée un site et donc
j'ai attendu la fin de mes études quand
même et puis deux ans après voilà le
site est en ligne
donc le site goal bing.com pourquoi
camping en camping ça vient d'eux je
vous avoue j'ai mis un peu de temps à
trouver le nom mais ça vient d'eux
maugard donne et camping donc c'est la
contraction ce camping parce que c'est
ça posait la question rédaction s'est
alors on peut faire le parallèle avec
des sites comme airbnb ou des
particuliers proposent leur domicile en
fait pour des voyageurs pourquoi avoir
opté pour une solution payante comme
airbnb pas pour une solution gratuite
finalement alors tout d'abord pour avoir
plus de verdun parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui avec la crise avec la
l'aspect financier un site plus de
personnes à proposer leur jardin si on
leur dit on accueillait des campeurs
dans votre jardin vous aurez moins de
succès s'il n'y a pas d'aspect monétaire
donc déjà c'est la région numéro 1 et
l'autre raison tout simplement pour que
l'entreprise puisse fonctionner parce
que c'est ce que sans argent belle
entreprise voilà enfin il faut quand
même qu'on puisse percevoir quelques
commissions donc si tout est gratuit
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
commission pour l'instant on n'est pas
des munitions venez pas révélé récemment
à changer ça pourra changer - si le site
ça coûte combien pour l'instant oui une
tente alors de me poser sa toile hard on
aimerait un terrain proposé cela posé sa
tente ça sent comme une carte aux
caravanes et alors les prix varient de 1
par exemple de 1 euro pour quelqu'un qui
dont l'aspect financier rooney prenait 1
euro par nuit et par personne jusqu'à 20
25 euros
mais après certains prix peuvent être
exagéré mais comme c'est le début c'est
vrai que voilà c'est les propriétaires
qui fixe les prix eux mêmes alors moi je
conseille aux campeurs de contacter
quand même les propriétaires pour pour
voir s'il ya un arrangement possible
surtout si vous êtes plusieurs personnes
parce que ça commence à chiffrer après
et alors si ces prix sont fixés en
fonction des services commencé en
fonction de la région touristique s'il
ya ainsi par exemple vous êtes à côté du
château de versailles
mais forcément il y aura des touristes
qui vont qui vont être intéressés par
venir camper camper chez vous bon ça en
fonction de la zone touristique et c'est
en fonction aussi des services que vous
proposez si vous proposez par exemple ne
serait ce qu'une douche chaude ça sera
toujours bien pour des campeurs qui qui
recherchent un minimum de confort après
vous pouvez proposer un accès à une
piscine
le barbecue la cuisine le petit déjeuner
il n'y a pas de limite mais ça on le
voit sur les sites en fait chaque profil
du coup en musique quels services sont
disponibles
s'il y a douch s'il ya plus voilà et
puis même chaque hôte peut détailler
aussi les activités qu'il est possible
de faire aux alentours
est-ce que vous vérifiez un petit peu
l'état des jardins l'état de des
services qui sont proposés parce que
alors pour l'instant je me déplace pas
dans chaque jardin mais je vérifie oui
la la la si le 6 le jardin à l'air à
l'air suspect je préfère ne pas le
mettre en ligne un jeu conçu ce fait
c'est surtout assas il ya plein de
bosses et s'il est en carton pape lancés
çà tombe dessus
non non non ça je sache je ne vérifie
pas mes vacances que je vérifie c'est
qu'ils aient pas de ça soit bien des
particuliers n'est pas des
professionnels
voilà vous vous limitez au barreau
particulier c'est à dire moins de six
places voilà alors la loi interdit de
dépasser six emplacements pour un
particulier
au delà il faut se déclarer en tant que
terrain de camping donc moi je je je
fixe une limite sur le site où naquit y
ait pas plus de six emplacements où 20
personnes
ah oui par exemple megaton tempête 12,2
dans quoi non c'est bien faire sa
personne on a forcément on peut se
demander comment ce site est perçu par
bas par les professionnels on est allé
du coup dans un camping à versailles
demandé au directeur s'il ne considérait
pas ça comme de la concurrence déloyale
je vous propose d'écouter sa réponse
c'est forcément un nouveau mode
d'hébergement
après ça reste je pense très anecdotique
mais au stade où ça en est donc je pense
pas qu'on puisse parler de concurrence
en tant que tel pour le camping de
versailles puisque puisque le volume
dont on parle mais n'est pas encore
forcément important après dans le
contenu c'est forcément c'est forcément
quelque chose qui qui se rapproche de
nos secteurs d'activité dont il
conviendra d'apprécier le développement
et de surveiller le développement donc
un concept à surveiller mais qui
pourtant point ce temps ne fait pas peur
vous êtes d'ailleurs renseigné auprès de
la fédération française du camping
savoir si tout était en règle et c'est
justement il vous faudra vous attaquer
là dessus donc ils m'ont confirmé que
tout était légal
donc ça m'a beaucoup rassuré aussi de
voir que eux aussi tu es conscient qu'il
n'y aurait pas de problème est qu'on en
parlait tout à l'heure sur le côté de la
commission qui son côté du contrôle
vous allez proposer prochainement de
nouveaux services alors elle pouvait un
peu les détails et ça va être des
commentaires par exemple sur les profils
ça va être des garanties aujourd'hui le
site est entièrement basée sur la
confiance et pour assurer une certaine
confiance mais il faut développer tous
ces services ne serait-ce que pose
proposé de mettre un commentaire après
être allés camper chez quelqu'un par
exemple le paiement en ligne peut-être à
la ajouté ajoutez une assurance
supplémentaire pour pour les
propriétaires donc tous ces services
vont venir dans les mois qui viennent
une assurance complémentaire c'est à
dire c'est à dire pour en cas de dégâts
car si on casse la douche en allant
prendre sa douche vous allez en faire un
pauvre un pouf malheureux dans la piste
vous vous êtes tout juste diplômés oui
pour l'instant donc que vous avez ce
site internet vous pensez grâce à ces
commissions
finalement être entrepreneur grâce à ce
site dans le futur alors pour l'instant
c'est vrai que j'ai eu la chance de
faire mes études en alternance donc je
touche une indemnité pôle emploi ce qui
me permet de pouvoir survivre on va dire
et donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je
suis un mordu d'entrepreneuriat donc
j'ai envie de continuer dans cette dans
cette aventure et et on verra on verra
l'avenir si je peux en vivre
et là vous avez combien d'inscrits
niveau des parcours l'instant il ya 150
membres dont 61 61 terrain et le reste
donc c'est les campeurs le reste voilà
c'est des campeurs alors il ya un site
concurrent qui existent déjà comme vous
dans mon jardin au point com comment
vous comptez vous différencier alors
comme dans mon jardin points comme il
faut savoir que dans ces terrains alors
et conquis des des beaucoup de cas mais
dans ces termes à une majorité de
terrain sont des professionnels des
campings et moi je trouve que ça ne
sorte du concept pour le coup et donc
moi j'ai interdit tous les
professionnels devront enfin de proposer
un terrain sur le site parce que c'est
n'a rien à voir au concept
donc moi je me différencie comme ça et
puis peut-être après avec vos frontières
de futures
vous nous parlez d'un certain nombre
d'inscrits pour l'instant il ya déjà des
personnes qui ont campé gens c'est alors
effectivement oui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même j'ai alors vous avez
des retours non je vais avoir des
retours sur facebook j'ai demandé via la
page facebook de me contacter les camps
par des caravaniers les terrains peuvent
aussi accueillir des cas voilà c'est pas
uniquement germanique pas de caresser
que c'était cool en toile notamment
chaque hôte peut définir si l'accueil
des tentes des caravanes des camping
cars et au niveau géographique ça
fonctionne sur toute la france et on
peut dire même partout parce qu'il ya un
terrain kenyan terrain au brésil un
terrain au canada un terrain si enfin il
ya des terrains peut pas les yvelines
alors vas-y vas-y vinoy son prêteur de
leur terrain j'espère l'espère bien
encore voilà j'ai voyagé premier contact
mais j'espère que ça va venir points
sont peut-être des contacts avec des
chambres d'hôtes je crois oui voilà un
contact avec une chambre d'hôte
après voilà moi je serais vraiment
preneur de trouver quelques autres dans
le coin pour pouvoir parler avec eux
pour m'aider à développer le concept
parce que par exemple à ce que vous avez
des campeurs qui voudraient visiter le
château de versailles qui sont justement
la recherche d'un terrain si on fait un
appel à lancer il ya des appels tous les
jours sur la page facebook qui défilent
mais pour l'instant je peux encore le
château de versailles mais peut-être ça
viendra donc appel aux intéressés à la
merci beaucoup merci à vous claire on
continue avec les uns font plus
d'enfants en plus et au 1er juillet donc
comme chaque année beaucoup de
changements dans vos factures quelques
exemples la tva sur les services à la
personne comme les travaux de jardinage
ou de ménages vont passer de 7 à 19,6
pour cent l'allocation chômage est
revalorisé plus 0,6 pour cent ça
représente entre 7 à 17 centimes
supplémentaires par jour
la couverture maladie universelle cmu
est quant à elle est élargie 750 mille
personnes supplémentaires y auront droit
le prix du gaz augmente de 0,5 pour cent
pour les ménages mais diminuera de 0,7
pour cent pour les professionnels les
coûts d'itinérance pour la téléphonie
mobile avons diminué par exemple coût
d'accès à internet depuis l'union
européenne baissera 2 36% en baisse de
36%
ça signifie 45 centimes maximum par
mégaoctet idem pour les appels et les
sms à l'étranger qui passeront de 17 et
11 % respectivement
enfin l'éclairage nocturne est
réglementée nous en parlions dans la
chronique la semaine dernière de 1h à 7h
du matin les vitrines magasins bureaux
de vraux éteindre leur lumière sur ce
sujet on a demandé à la poste une
entreprise comme si cela allait changer
quelque chose pour eux je vous propose
d'écouter la directrice du courrier des
yvelines
on engage est déjà dans une démarche de
développement durable donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on vérifie et qu'on a sous
pilotage depuis un moment
au delà de l'obligation réglementaire ça
correspond à une des valeurs de
l'entreprise sur le respect et puis
l'engagement sociétal nos établissements
étaient toutes les lumières au plus tard
à 17 heures sauf aubergenville qui
travaillent jusqu'à 20 heures et la
pique de bois d'arcy qui travaillent 24
heures sur 24 six jours sur sept on voir
clair que certaines entreprises ont déjà
pris de l'avancé puis une autre
augmentation celle du prix du tabac
comme ça augmente tout le 15 juillet de
20 centimes allez un autre sujet pour
tout autre sujet des bornes électriques
et sur les parking d'ikea
le groupe a acheté des bornes pour
recharger ses voitures électriques au
groupe bolloré
elles sont installées sur les sept
magasins dits de le france dont plaisir
et vélizy la cible les conducteurs
d'autolib évidemment qui vous recherchez
chargé gratuitement leur véhicule
pendant leurs courses pour ceux qui ont
opté pour la moue ville de conflans
sainte honorine
les bornes sont compatibles pas de souci
attention tout de même ce n'est pas une
station le conteur continuera de tourner
voilà moi j'avais une petite blague là
dessus c'est que je suis étonné
qu'autolib a jusqu à ikea % forte des
grands meubles c'est tout si quand même
automne y voit là il faudra rentrer dans
sa voiture
des meubles ikea c'est peut-être un peu
petites voitures et lots merci on en
avait déjà parlé dans votre chronique
oui on en parlait la semaine dernière
il y à une social auquel est mêlé le
merci c'est dans le site internet ou des
porteurs de projets mais cherche des
financements via des particuliers c'est
par des prêts solidaires dont beaucoup
viennent de la vallée de chevreuse on en
parler puisque ce parc naturel est
partenaire du site
un sixième projet monterai par ce parc
vient de réussir sa collecte de prêts
solidaires
en tout les porteurs porteurs de projets
donc lié à ce parc ont récolté 41 1200
euros par le biais de 128 prêteurs et
puis à noter il reste encore un projet
qui n'a pas obtenu la totalité de son
financement
il s'agit d'une boulangerie bio de
bullion qui souhaite ouvrir une seconde
boulangerie à saint rémy les chevreuse
il en est à la moitié de la somme
récoltée avis aux prêteurs ça vous
intéresse pire ça vous intéresserait le
bercy vient je vois que vous regarder
avec attention que vous leur prêtez de
l'argent décide comme ça le passé par
lots merci l'agenda première date une
formation sur les contrats de génération
qui aura lieu donc à la cité des métiers
attrape demain vendredi 5 juillet de 9h
à 12h30 au cours de cette matinée le
dispositif sera présenté et les clés
seront donnés pour mettre en place le
diagnostic de votre entreprise et
l'accord de négociations
le public visé donc les entreprises de
plus de 50 salariés
et puis une dernière date l'a dit c'est
l'association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique ouvre une
boutique éphémère à paris la semaine
prochaine
les créateurs des villes des yvelines
qui ont été financés par l'adie
exposeront et vendront leurs créations
produits et services alors ça peut aller
du prêt-à-porter mais aussi en passant
par les jouets en bois les accessoires
ou les produits cosmétiques donc du 8 au
12 juillet l'après midi de 14 heures à
19 heures et puis le pour le programme
jour par jour je vous propose de
regarder sur le site de l'as dit voilà
merci car chronicle que c'était la
dernière chronique de la saison était la
dernière de son prochain adversaire